[Music]
i'm ben
and i'm dion we're leaders on the chrome
team and the two of us have been working
together on the web platform for many
years now
it's been fun to watch as websites of
evolve from simple connected documents
to today's rich interactive web apps the
web has become
a high performance general purpose
computing platform
used by billions of people all across
the globe
and the web's growth has accelerated in
the last year as the pandemic has pushed
more of our daily interactions online
triggering a rush to improve web
experiences
as usage spikes and for us this
reinforces the importance of the web
and the need for all of us to work
together to make it better now we've
seen many computing platforms rise
and fall over the past decades one
thing's really clear
the old adage evolve or die plays a
major role in the ongoing relevance of
any platform
now the web has evolved a great deal
over the years and looking forward
i think the pace of evolution is
accelerating as it kind of has to to
keep
pace with tech and society generally so
at google i o this year
we have a number of sessions that will
bring you up to speed
on some of the latest developments in
the web and in this session
we'll give you a quick summary of what
we think are the key themes that you
should keep in mind
this year and we'll point you to where
you can learn more
and go deeper we're going to start with
privacy
explaining how the web is evolving to
enable
a private browsing experience for all
users by default next we'll cover how
the web is enabling a new generation of
powerful
fast and seamless web applications and a
fantastic user experience
and finally we'll summarize the work
we're doing to help developers be
productive
and successful with the web so let's get
started with
privacy and we'll do that by talking
about sandboxes
modern browsers are built around the
metaphor of a sandbox
each website you visit is isolated by
default from the rest of your system
including from websites and other open
tabs just as though it were surrounded
by virtual walls like those of a sandbox
in a garden
now chrome's innovated with the browser
sandbox model from its earliest days
first by isolating each website into its
own process
and more recently expanding on that to
isolate
each cross-site iframe on a web page
into its own process
we're taking this same approach with
user data and tracking
building a sort of privacy sandbox that
seeks
to keep all of your information safe and
secure within your browser
resulting in a web where your identity
and activity
are private by default
we announced the privacy sandbox effort
two years ago as an
open initiative a collaboration with the
community to bring this vision to life
while also being careful to help
transition the web ecosystem
to a new model in a thoughtful
deliberate way
we'd like to give you an update on our
progress our first step
announcing google i o two years ago was
changing the behavior of cookies in
chrome
moving them from being visible across
websites by default
to being visible only to the same
website that set them
before this change it wasn't really
clear whether a cookie was intended for
first party or third-party use
and browsers needed to observe how
cookies were used in the wild to infer
their purpose
this also created a security problem
because this wide default visibility of
cookies
exposed users to cross-site request
forgery attacks
based on third parties observing the
information in these cookies
now developers are required to opt in to
use cookies across sites
as so-called third-party cookies and in
turn browsers can then disable such
cookies in a very straightforward manner
this privacy preserving default behavior
is now enforced in chrome
edge and very soon firefox next we've
been collaborating with the ecosystem
on a new family of apis that provide
privacy preserving alternatives to use
cases
that today rely on third party cookies
such as federated login
personalized ads and conversion tracking
to clarify how these apis are
approaching this challenge
let's take a closer look at one of them
the attribution reporting api
so a key aspect of any web business is
how you grow your user audience
and that often involves advertising to
increase traffic
on the other side of those ad dollars
content publishers on the web
often rely on revenue from
advertisements to make their business
model work
finding out how many users actually
clicked on the ad
and whether those users subsequently did
something like sign up for a newsletter
or
complete a purchase is an important part
of this model
traditionally this measurement is
performed by tracking the user
from before and after the click across
websites
with a third-party cookie so how can we
do this in a way that
doesn't involve tracking that user well
inter attribution reporting using this
proposed api
no user identifying data is shared
between the sites
instead it's the browser that keeps
track of the ad conversion
later the browser sends an encrypted
report
to the advertiser for each of these
conversion events
but it adds time delays and noise to
these reports
to further stifle attempts to identify
users
this technique is broadly known as
differential privacy
this approach enables both parties to
still be able to measure the
effectiveness of their ad campaigns
and to understand what behavior the ads
are able to drive and to do so
without tracking the user across sites
now attribution reporting is one of many
new api proposals
in the privacy sandbox project it's
available for use as a chrome origin
trials experiment today
along with several other apis and will
ship more throughout the course of the
year
as we work with all of you across the
ecosystem to bring these new apis to the
web platform
we're also moving forward with
preparations to phase out third party
cookies
and implementing protection against
other forms of covert tracking
and we've got more details on what to do
with your own cookies today
in the technical sessions so the privacy
sandbox project
represents a substantial evolution of
the web platform
enabling privacy by default while also
preserving critical web use cases a
change this large
and fundamental to the web will take
time
but we're committed to this work and the
benefits it will bring to web
users globally the web has evolved into
a powerful application platform
enabling anyone with a modern browser on
nearly any kind of computing device
to get access to category leading
experiences that load fast and run
seamlessly
and devices like chromebooks show how
access to the web can be made affordable
safe
and simple with no need to become an
expert at maintaining
the underlying operating system for
years now we've been on a mission to
ensure the web has
all of the capabilities needed to bring
state-of-the-art computing experiences
to the platform
and since we last spoke to you at i o
the web's gained a significant array of
new capabilities
we'd like to highlight a few of these
for you one area we've been working on
has been making it easy for users to
seamlessly re-engage
with web apps now this has been possible
for a few years
to easily add web apps as icons to
native launchers
across both mobile and desktop and is
one of my favorite platform features
but now we want to talk about how we've
been deepening this integration between
web apps
and the underlying os with the new app
shortcuts feature
web apps can expose quick actions on
operating systems
that support this feature such as
android chrome os
windows and mac os and with the badging
api
web apps can give the user a subtle
prompt that there's an opportunity to
re-engage
by decorating the apps icon soon
we'll be shipping a chrome origin trial
experiment of another new api
declarative link capturing that enables
installed web apps to launch
automatically when the user clicks on an
appropriate link
now this could also prevent multiple
instances of the same app from opening
so you don't have like 10 tabs with the
same web app in it
we've also recently improved chrome's
web app installation ui
on desktop we now show an omnibox icon
and provide in-product help to explain
this feature to users
and on android we've made the dialog
look richer
and more familiar to users and we've
made it easy for developers to populate
the dialog
with custom images and text that are
specified in the web apps manifest file
so those are ways that we're improving
the web's integration
with os launchers we're also adding
other os integrations such as the
multi-screen window placement api
which allows web apps to discover all of
the connected displays
control where the window is placed on
those screens
this is actually a pretty handy feature
these days for web-based presentation
and video conferencing apps
now web apps can finally read and write
to the user's local file system using
the file system access api
enabling apps like gravity designer and
photop
to provide a much more seamless user
experience persisting state to disk
and working with existing files we're
also working on a new file handling api
that would allow web applications to be
registered as
file type handlers enabling users to
open files directly in a web app
from os file browsers we hope to ship an
experimental release
of this api later this year now let's
talk about peripheral devices
things like special purpose keyboards
game controllers digital pianos headsets
and more
now the web's had the ability to
communicate with bluetooth and midi
devices for some time
but several new apis now enable support
for a broader collection
of these devices many of these
communicate using the
hid protocol the web now has an api for
this
in web hid nintendo's joy-con controller
is an example of a device
that supports this protocol
for gamepad style controllers the
industry standard gamepad api
is now supported by the web as well and
this enables
uncompromising gameplay with apps like
stadia in the browser
and you can also use a gamepad to
control the chrome dyno in style
the web also now supports serial ports
with the web serial api this actually
unlocks one of my favorite new use cases
piper make it's a block based editor
that allows you to program a raspberry
pi
pico all you have to do is simply plug
in the device to any computer
open a browser and off you go no need to
install software or mess with drivers
all thanks to web serial now with these
and other new web capabilities you can
bring deeply integrated
seamless experiences to users everywhere
right through the browser
google maps holds a special place in our
hearts as a singularly influential web
app when it first launched over 15 years
ago
maps continues to innovate on the web
several years ago they embraced webgl
enabling hardware accelerated graphics
and delivered a much more powerful
maps ui in the process last year the
maps team enabled those same webgl
accelerated map capabilities to be used
in your
web app via the maps javascript api
this year the team has something new to
share
join me in welcoming travis macphail the
team's engineering lead
who will tell us more about it we're
constantly amazed by all the ways you've
used your skill
your creativity and google's knowledge
of the real world
to build an unbelievable variety of
experiences
that have truly reimagined the map
and it's in that spirit today during the
developer keynote
we announced the beta release of two new
features that give you
unprecedented control of the base map
tilt and rotation
and webgl overlay view with these
features
you can manipulate the map in three
dimensions for the first time
while taking advantage of the power of
the same webgl context
we use to render the base map for the
first time ever
you can build not just on top of the map
but you can build with it
let's take a quick look at how it works
to make things
easy i'm using 3js a popular web
graphics library
to render a 3d object on the map i've
set up a basic web app
that loads the map centered on a
location in the yucatan peninsula of
mexico
and i'm using a map id so that i can use
the vector map and apply some custom
styling
the first thing i need to do is
implement webgl overlay view
by extending google.maps.webgl
overlayview
the webgl overlay exposes a set of hooks
into the lifecycle of the webgl
rendering context of the basemap
for today we'll keep things as simple as
possible
and focus on just three of them the
first
on add is called when the overlay
instance is created
the second on context restored is called
once the rendering context is available
and the third on draw is where the map
and anything else you specify is
actually rendered
and on add i'm going to set up
everything that the scene needs that
doesn't require
immediate access to the rendering
context i start by creating a new 3js
scene
i also create a camera that represents
the viewport
of the scene in this case a perspective
camera
next the scene needs at least one light
source
so that any rendered objects are
illuminated in the scene
for this example ambient light is used
to equally illuminate all objects in our
scene
now i'm ready to add my 3d object using
the gltf loader
once the object is loaded i scale and
rotate it
to have it render just right then i add
it to the scene
and on context restored i configure the
3js webgl renderer
passing it the map's rendering context
and information about the viewport
once the object renders i also want to
animate the camera
to give my users a dynamic view of the
object
so i call move camera in the set
animation loop function of the renderer
i also increment tilt heading and zoom
just a little bit in each frame to
create a nice downward spiral motion
alright time to render the 3js camera
needs a projection matrix so that it
knows how to render latitude and
longitude coordinates in the 3d world of
the map
to the 2d coordinates of the screen now
i don't know about you but matrix
transforms
are not my idea of a good time so to
save you a bunch of math
we hand you a transformer object that
has the from lat long
altitude function which creates this
matrix for you
i pass it the lat line coordinates where
i want the model to appear
and i set the return value as a camera
projection matrix
all that's left is to clear the gl state
tail webgl overlay view i want to redraw
by calling request redraw
on the webgl overlayview instance and
render the scene
and finally i create an instance of my
class
and set the map instance i want it
applied to
and this is the result not too bad for a
few minutes of coding right
tilt and rotation and webgl overlay view
are just the latest way
we're delivering on our commitment to
you we have a lot more planned
and we can't wait to see all the ways
you'll come up with to reimagine the map
all over again and show us what's next
back to you dion thanks travis
webgl brought a whole new level of
graphics performance to the web
when it became available several years
ago we're currently working closely with
the graphics and web communities
on web gpu a new next generation
graphics api designed from the ground up
to unlock a whole new level of graphics
performance on the web
taking inspiration from low-level apis
like vulcan
metal and direct3d 12.
web gpu is still very experimental but
holds exciting promise for the future
another key performance technology is
webassembly
which provides a standard for compiling
code to a fast and efficient format that
can be executed in the browser
by modern javascript engines like v8 we
recently gave webassembly
a major performance boost by
implementing support for
simd processor instructions in v8
which enables certain classes of apps to
run much faster
google meet provides a powerful example
of simd in action
like any video conferencing app meet has
to pay careful attention
to their performance budget and there's
a constant tension between processing
the video
in order to enhance it and maintaining a
smooth low latency stream
using v8's experimental origin trial of
simd
the meat team achieved a 200 percent
performance gain
on their in browser media processing
pipeline
and this in turn gave them the budget to
enable a background blur feature for
most of their users
that was powered by tensorflow in the
browser
we're planning to ship simd to all
chrome users
in the coming months now webassembly is
also frequently used to bring
non-javascript code bases to the web
unlocking them for new use cases for
example the developers behind the
offline first sync engine
replicash were able to compile their ros
code to webassembly
enabling web developers to seamlessly
incorporate it
into their web app to ease with code
porting
va added threading support to
webassembly back in 2019
but it was only enabled for desktop
operating systems
we're pleased to share today that chrome
for android gained web assembly threads
as of chrome 88 in january of this year
we've also enhanced v8's webassembly
debugging experience
with support for break points and
variable inspection
right there in chrome devtools we're so
excited to see what you deliver
with the universal runtime that works on
client or server
is sandbox and wicked fast that's
webassembly
so the va team has also been hard at
work at squeezing even more
javascript performance out of its engine
so in addition to interpreting
javascript v8 also compiles code
on the fly for more efficient execution
and the team has implemented a whole new
compiler
called spark plug of course sometimes
the best way to improve code execution
performance is to not execute any code
at all
and in this spirit earlier this year we
shipped a new chrome feature to some
users
called intensive timer throttling that
detects when a browser tab has been in
the background for more than five
minutes
and as long as the tab isn't playing any
audio or video
chrome slows down how frequently it
executes timer-based javascript code
on that tab we've also applied this
concept with css
by shipping support for a new css
property called content visibility
when you set this property to auto on an
element
you're giving the browser permission to
skip rendering the contents
of that element tree if it isn't
currently visible
on the user's display and this can lead
to a dramatic speed boost
for content heavy sites now there's a
ton of innovation happening on the web
platform
to enable significantly faster runtime
performance of your web apps
now in addition to the work that's
happening to expand the power and
performance of the web
the platform's also evolving to deliver
a more instant and seamless experience
for users
in chrome 87 released in november last
year
we added a so-called back forward cache
to chrome
on android or bf catch for sure
bf cache keeps some web pages loaded in
memory
after you navigate away from them so if
a user clicks back
or forward the page is displayed
instantly
and it turns out one in five navigations
on mobile
are doing exactly that moving backwards
or forward through the history stack
so this feature drives a really big
impact
now while today chrome's bf cache
implementation is
available on android does have some
limitations we are planning to expand it
to the chrome desktop platform soon
another way
we're expanding instant experiences is
by
revisiting the notion of pre-rendering
pages
pre-rendering is the technique of
loading all of the web pages resources
and even rendering the dom before the
user clicks on a link so it can be
displayed truly instantly
now this is hard to get right because
preloading these pages can also cause
side effects if the page does something
like sign out
or if the page plays audio then it can
also start playing in a mysterious way
also it can leak some user information
if it's done across
sites but when pre-rendering is done
right
it provides this powerful instant
click-through experience for the user
so we're working on new approaches to
pre-rendering
that are private and safe one of these
involves a new pre-rendering api
that would enable developers to
experiment with this on same site
pre-loading
later this year the transitions are
another important aspect of the user
experience
ensuring that users are able to shift
their context as they navigate the web
and get right to where they want to go
one fun simple feature with a big impact
is scroll
to text added to chrome 80 in february
of last year
by adding a new type of expression to
the end of your url
browsers can position the viewport to a
specific text element
and highlight it in some way soon we'll
be shipping a version of this api that
scrolls to images
and we're exploring other element types
too with the new document transition
apis that are coming to chrome soon as
experiments
we're also building in support for a
number of graphical transitions
between elements enabling the user to
perceive a seamless experience
as they move between states of your web
app
we're also working to make security more
seamless on the web
and one feature i'm particularly excited
about is cross-device
one-time passwords for the web one-time
passwords are these numeric codes that
some sites can send you
to log in now this feature enables you
to receive one of these one-time
passwords on your android phone
and then have that automatically
transferred to your chrome browser
running on some other device like a
laptop all of these new web capabilities
are exciting
but as the pace of web evolution
accelerates so
too does the complexity we face as web
developers and keeping track of
everything we're working to make the web
easier for developers and partnering
with the broader ecosystem to understand
and address the platform's top pain
points to understand
our latest recommendations for web
development visit
web.dev the site includes detailed
tutorials on
key topics the latest news and it also
provides
access to our lighthouse website
auditing tool
now with lighthouse you get a
comprehensive report on how to improve
your website
across a variety of categories such as
performance
accessibility and seo we're continually
updating lighthouse guidance to give you
the very best insights
that we can we found that three of
lighthouse's performance metrics are
particularly impactful on the user
experience
we call these core webvidors
and collectively they measure how fast a
site displays key content
how responsive the site is for the first
interaction
and how much the site's layout shifts
around
sites across the web are using call web
vitals as a north star for
performance and are reporting
encouraging results
for example the italian publisher jedi
saw an 8 improvement in the bounce rate
on their mobile article pages
they did this by implementing a branded
placeholder
in order to reserve space for ads in
their ad slots on the page
which improved their layout stability
and then
by deferring loading of some of their
javascript code until
after the page was visible they improved
the perceived page loading speed
web content and commerce platforms are
also investing
in core web vitals to improve the
performance of
all of their hosted sites for example
shopify and wix implemented dashboards
in their admin consoles that puts
performance
front and center for site owners and the
wordpress community has also shipped
performance oriented editions such as
lazy loading for images and iframes
we've also updated sitekit which is
google's official plugin for
wordpress with support for measuring
core web vitals
and it also makes specific improvement
recommendations to developers
google search has also announced the
core web vitals will
soon be a part of how pages are ranked
in search results
we think this is particularly exciting
as it magnifies the benefit
of call web vitals to you the developer
the investment will not only give your
users a better experience
but it will help them find your site
through search now we spend a good
amount of time listening to developers
both in small gatherings and through
scaled developer surveys
one of the common themes we consistently
hear
is the importance to developers of
cross-browser compatibility
so this year we recently announced our
participation in a cross-industry effort
called compat 2021 which aims to fix
the top five browser compatibility pain
points as voted on by web developers
which shockingly all happened to be css
related
and speaking of css we're seeing an
exciting renaissance in this area
we even have our own modern day zen
garden
css flexbox and grid have been embraced
by developers
as major improvements for creating page
layouts
and learnings from years of css
frameworks like sas
are being baked into the platform such
as nesting
and along with container queries you
know which is your most requested
feature i think for css
you'll be able to create style sheets
that are more modular and reusable
by enabling rules that are scoped
naturally to their local context
versus acting so globally now one of
chrome's
most popular features is its suite of
built-in developer tools
which give you an incredibly powerful
toolkit that can function as your web
development co-pilot
over the past year we've enhanced
devtools with a bevy
of new improvements ranging from a new
color picker
improved warnings and linting of pwas a
core web vitals overlay
dedicated css flexbox debugging dropped
frame visualization
support for css and javascript and much
more
and devtools is also a platform because
it supports extensions
and one example of a new extension is
the angular devtools chrome extension
which provides debugging and performance
profiling support that's specific
to angular apps so check out our chrome
dev tools session
to deep dive into all of this and learn
more about our new devtools features
the web is evolving in fundamental ways
so it doesn't become extinct
it's becoming private by default with
new apis
that protect user privacy and it also
continues to gain powerful new
capabilities that broaden what's
possible on the platform
providing for better user experiences
lastly
we're committed to partnering with you
in the ecosystem as the web evolves
to make sure that you've got all of the
tools and guidance for success
now you can dive deeper into many of
these improvements across the web
platform by checking out a number of
other sessions
many of which we've highlighted today at
this year's i o
so thanks for your time and we look
forward to seeing what you build
with the evolved capabilities of the
modern web
and if you're watching this during i o
week come find us an adventure
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
you